new information on a pfizer vaccine for
those between the ages of 12
and 15 it could be ready as soon as next
week but the news comes with really
mixed reactions
a news now reporter sally jeremiah live
outside the convention center
a location parents could soon take kids
to get the vaccine
sally
brian the health district is making it
easier for those
ages 16 and over to get vaccinated
now would drive out vaccinations soon
many of you could be bringing your
younger kids here
others want to still wait it out
when younger kids get a coveted
infection
the mortality is lower the morbidity is
lower
doctor mark khan with the kirk care
korean school of medicine says
our youth can transmit the disease so
vaccinating them
will protect others some parents agree
others do not
the thing that parents want to do
is have their children outlive them and
getting a vaccine will ensure that my
eldest who it just turned 17 she just
got her second shot
and so yeah we definitely wanted to
be freer and be able to go places and do
more things
our 13 year old was left without one and
so
we had this wonder when when will she be
able to get hers
shahab sargari says having his youngest
get the vaccine
puts them at ease they're thinking of
their future they're thinking of
this herd immunity that comes from you
know the masses getting the vaccine
and he can't wait for some normality in
his girls lives
now they can finally get back and get
off of zoom and get off of the group
text and go hang out
brett rogers is for the vaccine too
i'm excited about it and my kids are
excited about it they they understand
science they know how vaccines work
juan manuel linse a father of three is
concerned
about long-term risk these vaccines are
experimental i don't think that that'll
be the case but
but i cannot also
have them get the vaccine
and just hope for the best
dr khan also tells me it probably won't
take too long before we start
seeing those kids ages younger than 12
get the vaccine reporting live from the
convention center sally jaramillo 8 news
now